So you've got to see the stuff. There's a growing
trend which we expected for reporters to ask Joe
White, Joe Biden's White House press secretary,
Jen Psaki, tough questions during press briefings
that aren't actually tough questions. They're
just sort of fake drama and attack lines. And
I'm the first person to tell you that every press
secretary, regardless of party, should get tough
questions, real tough questions, questions like
Joe Biden promised 2000 dollar checks right away
and we're three weeks in and talking about
fourteen hundred dollars. Explain. That's a
real question of urgent importance to the American
people. But what I'm going to play for you today
and what we've seen in the press briefing room
for two and a half weeks now under Joe Biden's
presidency, these aren't real tough questions.
These are ridiculous questions. So let's check out
some of these examples. Here is a reporter asking,
why won't Joe Biden call antifa terrorists?
What are the definitions of terrorists?
And why is the focus only on January 6th that
there was Jake Sullivan mentioned the focus on
domestic terrorism yesterday. This administration,
I think a lot of people want to know how does this
administration define the term domestic terrorist?
In what way? Well, it does include antifa
specifically. What how do you set those parameters
for domestic terrorists, especially as we see,
you know, a lot of focus on the January six,
maybe not as much focus on some of the extremism
and violence in the north, the northwest?
Well, I've answered a version of this
question on a couple of times before,
but I know everybody's not in the briefing
room every day. The reason we have the review,
which is not a political review, but is a review
done by our national security team, something tast
again to take a review of domestic violent
extremism will cover incidents across the board.
You sort of get the sense that Jen Psaki
deals with this, the way a parent deals with
an obstinate kid throwing a tantrum, sort of like
some amused detachment, but still having to remain
strict in order to control the situation and not
encourage bad behavior. And then a question that
sort of tries to paint teachers as these stubborn
adversaries refusing to go back to school. And Jen
Psaki does a good job of not letting the framing
be that teachers are bad and the enemy and are
going to have to be forced back those questions.
But go ahead. Will President Biden use the power
of the bully pulpit to help cajole teachers who
are unwilling to go back to schools to go back?
Well, what I'm just going to reject the premise
of the question. I will say I have teachers in
my family, as I'm sure many of you do.
They are the first people to tell you
that being teaching in the classroom and being
able to engage with kids in the classroom or
middle schoolers or high schoolers in the
classroom, it makes their job more enjoyable,
makes them more effective at what they do.
So she turns the question around
and it doesn't matter. The reporter keeps going
and then tries to incorrectly, inaccurately
summarize what Jen Psaki actually said.
Sounded like a yes with an asterisk.
I you if you are the spokesperson for the White
House, you could certainly say that, but you are
not. But you can ask me another question.
My second quick question is, last year
these briefings are there's there's an
attempt to turn these briefings into a joke,
but for very different reasons than they were a
joke under Trump's White House press secretary,
Kayleigh McEnany. Another game that they're
playing is saying, you know, Biden said unity.
Biden promised bipartisanship, but no
Republicans are supporting the covid bill. So
is this evidence that Joe Biden is
abandoning bipartisanship and unity?
And Jen Psaki is receiving this question all the
time and she's doing a good job answering it.
Given the president's remarks
earlier and his change of tone,
it does seem that he is now OK, if this does
happen just with Democratic support, despite
those hopes and despite his calls for unity.
Well, first of all, the president ran on the
on unifying the country and putting forward
ideas that would help address the crises we're
facing. He didn't run on a promise to unite
the Democratic and Republican Party into one.
Party in Washington, this package has the vast
majority of support from the American public.
I'm fine with the question and she should keep
answering it this way. But it needs to be said
really clearly, Joe Biden made a proposal and
then met with Republicans to hear their side,
to get their thoughts, to get a sense of what they
want. Republicans proposed something absurd. They
proposed a package less than one third the
size of what Democrats and Joe Biden want
and what Joe Biden and Democrats want
is popular with the American people.
Joe Biden has a 69 percent approval rating on
covid, 63 percent approval overall. You don't get
that with just Democrats. Trump never even got to
50 percent approval on one day of his presidency.
And Joe Biden's already at 63. Overall, 69
Unkovic. You can lead a horse to water, but
you can't make them drink. Joe Biden engaged with
Republicans. The American people want something
else. Democrats want something else. And Joe
Biden wants something else. And it's Joe Biden's
responsibility to get it done at some point. You
can't keep waiting around for bad faith actors.
So I guess this is sort of how it's going to be.
I would prefer, rather than silly non gotchas,
that they actually put together some serious,
well calibrated, tough questions. That's what I
would like to see. It's not clear that that's
actually going to happen. And as we saw very
early on in Joe Biden's presidency, it's not
clear that, you know, the as she points out,
unity and bipartisanship don't mean you have to
give up everything to get a Republican to vote
with you when you have the country more behind
you and more behind these ideas than they ever
were behind anything Donald Trump did. At
some point, you have to just say, listen,
I offered everything. We offered the meetings
we offer. What they want is ridiculous. We're
not going to do it. It's not what the American
people want. At a certain point, you have to do
that. It's your responsibility. And I hope that
that's actually what Joe Biden is doing now.